thank you for coming today my name is
Dora I'm one of the partners here at Y
Combinator and today we're going to talk
with have a conversation with ich Magog
who is the CEO and founder of gobble
which creates and delivers 15-minute pan
dinners to you
I am personally a happy customer it's
great for people who don't have time to
do grocery shopping prep ingredients
actually cook and then clean up
afterwards so so gobble started in 2011
and while it's doing pretty well today
it's growing around 100 million revenue
per week I believe it's gone through its
many ups and downs and so future my
today I want to talk to her about a
couple things one is evolution of her
business she's mostly been in the food
business but it's iterated her business
model many times and so I think it'd be
interesting to talk about that and then
to is something she's an expert in which
is grit and determination I think she's
one of the few people that I've seen
that just never gives up and so I think
in termination or one the qualities many
people think they have but when [ __ ]
hits the fan things start to fall apart
and so I think it's also interesting to
talk about so with that I would love to
welcome you to the stage thank you
[Applause]
so welcome oozma thank you for having me
thank you for coming so maybe we can
just briefly start from the very
beginning you were a student at Stanford
and I believe you start your first
company then which was correct new
client got this wrong is you help
students get jobs at banks and yes he's
obviously that didn't work out and you
did cobble instead but can you explain
why that didn't work out and what made
you think that you should just move on
from that idea
sure so back when I was at Stanford they
started this company out of my dorm room
and fun visual is that I had this like
you know 150 200 square foot room like
with no space and I lofted my bed like
five inches from the ceiling and stuffed
some like IKEA desks under my bed we
could only fit like three desks in there
I was a junior so I hired all these
freshman really smart freshmen as
interns and got a boyfriend so I could
sleep somewhere else for the business
joking and and then our dorm room became
our office and I hid the key in the
girls bathroom and people would come
between class and get the key from my
like pink shower caddy and then go into
my dorm room and work on our startup so
that was our house my first company in
Napa de and the idea was to help
students get jobs I was head of this
group Stanford women in business so we
were matching people to banks and law
firms and consulting firms and and I
worked on that for three years I
bootstrapped it and no one would fund me
they told me the idea was too nice or
what-have-you but really no one was
using LinkedIn at the time and all of
these students are looking for work so I
thought that we could really be the
LinkedIn for for students and it was all
centered around their interests and
student groups long story short the idea
was working and we were making we were
making money like these companies would
write us $20,000 $25,000 checks for
for annual subscriptions to my
recruiting website and it was a
two-sided marketplace so what really
happened is first of all I poured
everything I had into the business and
and my health went down the drain which
later leads to gobble but um
what ended up happening is I learned the
hard lesson that whoever pays you kind
of owns you and determines how your
product evolves so these banks and
consulting firms and all of them were
paying me and they wanted to recruit
students based on quotas based on like
their GPA or their race or their you
know other parts of their background
that didn't really have to do with if
they were a good cultural match and so
anyways I I was making money but the
mission and the the initial like a
vision and all of that of the business
of helping people find the good jobs
wasn't true anymore so I actually got to
a very dark place and ended up selling
the business so it could have worked but
the less and it could have worked longer
term but it wasn't the business I
initially intended and I'm not the kind
of person who you know was just gonna do
something to make money I want to do
something that I believe in so in our
third year we were taking off with law
firms there are thousands of law firms
and only tens of banks on Wall Street
and so I sold it to a company called law
works and basically their their
recruiting company and software and they
wanted to add community to their to
their offering at that time it was like
2010 and social and communities and all
of that where we're not as common as
they are now so you mentioned briefly
this is good transition and we talking
about gobble in the beginning your
health was going down the drain yeah how
did that actually turn into gobble
itself yeah and I'm sure as you all are
you know too familiar with starting a
company at least especially in the first
thousand days is very very lonely
very few people believe in the idea
outside of yourself and most people
think you're crazy
most people don't care about you and so
you're the only thing that keeps
yourself going and maybe your co-founder
your partner but your partner's sick of
hearing about it and your co-founder may
or may not work out so there's lots of
loneliness and and basically this I
became just very insular I stopped
visiting my family and my friends I was
working on the business but I was
staying up too late and then waking up
too late and then just eating like all
this takeout and soda and I think it not
only affects your physical health and I
gained a lot of weight but it also
affects your mental health as all of
that came to a head when my dad insisted
on visiting and I was here in California
my parents are in Texas and my dad is
the head of nutrition at UT Southwestern
and Texas so he spent 30 years of his
life studying diabetes obesity and
nutrition so and then at home he would
make sure we all ate home-cooked food
and like real good food so and your
parents always know when something's
wrong you can't lie to them it's just a
matter of time so um so anyways he like
got on a plane actually first he cooked
for three days and made all of this like
home-cooked Indian food stuffed it in
these like international suitcases that
were like you know nicely packed and
checked in everything's in foil and zip
locks and whatever flew here in a
California to my like little dingy
studio apartment and without even saying
hello comes in the apartment goes to the
fridge and starts like stuffing the food
in the fridge and it just showed like
his anger and sadness and emotion about
like me not taking care of myself and
how bad things had gotten and he warmed
a little plate of some sub Z which is
like a vegetable Indian dish with some
bread and rice and just put it in front
of me and I had this like IKEA
two-person dining table in a corner and
I ate this first bite and I just
I started crying uncontrollably because
the food was so good and it showed me
that I like that's how much I had lost
and it wasn't just nutrition it was like
a sense of self and being and that's
really easy to do um
and so anyways that first bite of my
dad's home cooking inspired gobble and
that moment was when I decided that the
home cooking and the sense of family
dinner is very important to me so the
first version on gobble if I got it
correctly it was a marketplace for
people to create home-cooked meals and
sell it on the marketplace
so that was 2011 and then I believe then
then one year later you turned it into
if I have this written down catering yes
and then a year later it was
personalized dinner service and then to
what it is pretty much what it's today
50 minute dinner kids so maybe you could
start off with if you remember your
one-liner for each four of those
business models to help us distinguish
the difference between those four
absolutely I definitely remember the
first one because it it's what I raised
our seed round off of so we started
after I ate that food I wanted to
replicate my dad in the bay area and I
posted on Craigslist and looked for moms
or dads that would cook for me anyway
the way that we described the idea it
ultimately became a marketplace for
personal chefs and and families and we
described it as peer-to-peer lasagna and
everyone remember that and just set it
and it was catchy and weird and and the
peer-to-peer economy was really hot at
the time Airbnb was just coming up Etsy
was coming up and there were all these
like rental or sharing startups in 2010
to 2012 so that's how he described the
marketplace Catering was just like
home-cooked food for office the
personalized dinner service was exactly
that it was meals personalized exactly
to your tastes and our current dinner
kits we describe as just as a meal prep
service 15-minute one pan cooking so
everyone who built the product always
remembers their
very first user who wasn't their mom or
dad or family do you remember that
person and what was he or she like yeah
so recently I met one of our very first
like 10 users the guy's name is she'll
tile and it's really funny I actually
met him and he was a user of ours in
2011 so now it's some seven eight years
later I met him a few weeks ago at a
wedding in New York and he was like are
you yeah and he's like I used to eat
your food and he you know your product
goes through so many iterations that
when someone remembers like the first
website of yours and all that those bugs
and things it's really special he was a
Stanford student and he would email us
like pages of feedback you know every
time you tried the food and so it was
kind of a the canonical early adopter
that's someone who really wants to work
with you and who wants to help improve
your company and like make it good for
them and for everybody else so in the
beginning you also did a lot of
unscalable things to get users I read
you you did promo cards everywhere you
went the Starbucks and I just bother
people - yes order from gobble so all of
those things probably didn't work but
anything that you remember that actually
works yeah and there are two things that
that worked and I was reflecting on this
one of them is um I guess the things
that work is when you're just starting
out you you can't throw a million
dollars into Facebook ads in one week
but it doesn't also work to just like
talk to ten individuals that's to
unscalable so it's all about reaching
like micro groups one thing I did is I
would go to my favorite I went to all my
favorite shops like coffee shops
restaurants laundromats whatever and I
actually bought card holders on on like
a whatever equipment website and made
promo cards that were business card size
and it said like two free dinners gobble
comm and it and it had the restaurants
name on the back one of the first
valuable innovations or features that we
released into our product was the
ability to accept promo codes because
attribution of your growth is extremely
important from day one or else I can't
tell you what's working or not working
so there's zombie runners on California
Avenue this is coffee shop and and it's
inside a running store that what used to
be a movie theater it's very weird you
should go there it's my favorite coffee
shop and and so they put a little thing
at their at their register and it turned
out to be more effective than the nail
salons the laundromats anything else
another YC company order a head actually
for a while was very successful with
coffee shops and promos and ordering at
coffee shops one other thing was I
I spoke to as many like meetup groups or
moms groups and neighborhood groups as
possible and I would get them I would
always try to have an offer that was I
tested offers and I knew what would work
so every single one of them would send
my offer on their email list and it had
to be an email with your offer to a
group and that converted the attribution
point is very I think key there which is
even if you're doing a spray-and-pray
method of just like everyone used me at
least you know when they come in the
door were they actually absolutely yes
cool so again and going back to the
evolution of the business at what point
in each of the business model did you
realize oh this isn't it I gotta think
of something else right the funny thing
is that and so first of all we talked
about these business models all of that
was going on for from 2011 to 2014 so
between three and a half years which is
still roughly that thousand days of
finding product market fit we had four
different iterations to the product and
this is a minor little point but I know
that I think Michael Seibel spoke
recently and he said that he talked
about the difference between pivoting
and iterating and I thought that was
really important because people say
gobble pivoted but we didn't pivot we
didn't turn into some like you know
online video game we just it
and then found success and I think that
a lot of nuance is important because
pivoting I think you don't carry a lot
of your learnings with you
iterating is always building on your
previous learnings so with these
business models they and different
iterations and launches they all failed
for different reasons we had a market
place first and and everyone loved the
food because it was this authentic
small-batch home-cooked food from like
real people
Italian grandmas and Mexican moms and
like Ethiopian chefs and things and food
you can't get anywhere else
it's not like ruined by capitalism I
guess anyways that food wasn't scalable
so we started getting success with that
marketplace idea but when I asked this
like Italian mom and San Carlos to make
me 200 of her lasagna when she used to
make 20 a day it wasn't fun anymore
and she didn't want to make 200 and she
wasn't a caterer so that that model um
you know Airbnb is a peer-to-peer model
that can scale and it's sharing an asset
it's sharing a space this is a
peer-to-peer model that has a lot of
like break points at scale of quality
time capacity and so on so that that's
why the marketplace model didn't work we
were supply constrained not by the
number of chefs but by the juice we
could squeeze from each of our SKUs on
the marketplace then we pivoted to de
catering because we had built that
marketplace with seed funding and we
were we maybe had like a half a year of
money left or something but one of our
investors was very insistent that we had
our growth with money and we do
something that'll definitely make us
money and so I went into the catering
world frankly to me I think it's very
easy and and I didn't really want to do
it you just get we got like box.net and
Pinterest and these companies signed on
and they rarely quit and so you're just
making this money in the
background we did that we made good
money and we showed growth but the
problem is that when we went to raise
series a the investors asked how much of
your money is from families and the
model you're pitching and how much of
your money is from catering and from
enterprise and at that point some 75%
was from enterprise because when you do
something like that like the previous
startup lesson we learned all your
attention goes to what's giving you the
most money and so that that really
sucked because unless I wanted to build
a catering business then you know I
wasn't gonna get funding so we were in a
pinch then and I had to raise a bridge
round and wind down the catering
business which was hugely unpopular
because we were making lots of money but
it wasn't my long-term vision the vision
was that people don't have access to
this home-cooked food and I wanted to
crack it and figure it out and give it
to everyone so we wound that down
because it wasn't part of the long-term
vision the third month so then we
focused on this personalized dinner
service I still today think that the
power of personalization what Amazon
brings to e-commerce and what Netflix
and Spotify bring to movies and music
that level of personalization has not
taken off in food and just like Google
with search the company that cracks it
in food I think will be like the
long-term winner and have all these
learnings built on top of each other to
where you build a long-term sustainable
advantage so that's what we did with
that personalized dinner service we took
these chefs and and then we started
using restaurants and caterers and we
focused on the technology because that
that's what that's the talent that we
had in our headquarters we had engineers
and product people so we focused on the
tech to match to take we we allowed
people to give us whatever taste they
wanted so we ended up getting like
thousands of picky eaters and people who
like didn't eat nightshades and they
were vegan but they still didn't like
olives and lettuce and like crazy stuff
and I and no
what your tastes were I said I would
feed you and so anyway that that model
really stretched our technology and by
doing the hard thing we learned if
you're vegan and don't like lettuce what
are you eating I know I don't know like
lots of beans so you move the business
model a little bit each time or yes and
so one of the difficult things in doing
that is taking the risk and bringing
down your current business for hopefully
future success and that I think a lot of
people actually don't do that because
it's very very scary they just try keep
pushing the current model I'm trying to
make it work so was it scary for you and
like what was your thought process and
like actually just saying no not going
to do this enterprise catering anymore
even though it's making tons of money
right it was it was so scary
um it was really scary and and actually
some of our investors would like call me
into their office and just use it as
like me as a punching bag you know and
like sit down at their reclaimed wood
table and their kitchenette or something
and and they would like I'd be sitting
and it's stand-up and they'd be like and
and every time there's new startups
coming up the grass is always greener
because the investors know all your
problems and they don't know any of the
other problems so anyway so they would
be like this company mantri is starting
and this company order ahead is starting
and all these companies are starting and
like what are you doing and it was it
was much louder and much worse than that
and and so but you know I have found I
think that's what you mentioned earlier
about the grit and determination I don't
know if it's learned or what it is over
so many years I have found that I cannot
listen to anything there's nothing more
loud than like my gut and it's just when
you know something and you've been in it
for three years or thousands of days you
can't avoid it you know what you have to
do other people think about you like 1%
of the year and just in the one hour
meeting and so I think early on we put a
lot of weight
into investor meetings even into YC
partner meetings into all these meetings
and it can really throw you off your
game for a few days you're like oh this
one person didn't like my idea who am i
and it's just something you have to get
through and and I would always try to
justify each direction with like with
with logic and with market drawings and
one book that really helped me was Blue
Ocean Strategy it's my favorite business
book to date and it talks about how
companies broke through the noise in
existing industries talks about
Southwest Airlines yellowtail wine and
some like really interesting companies
and that no one thought would work so
you should and it gives you a framework
with which to think about your company
and I would draw that framework and keep
using it as my North Star in a previous
talk and let me read this so I get it
right you said something green
insightful which is product market fit
is not just an aha moment it's a
summation of lots of broad experiments
and micro learnings over many years can
you briefly expand on that like a common
mistake is for people when they look at
product market fit is to just look at
one metric and then if it moves in one
direction then that's good so what did
you look at the beginning and how did
you visualize this summation of stuff
yeah ultimately I think that product
market fit is the the center of the Venn
diagram of ability to grow on one side
and retention on the other side and so
if you look at our history um in the
marketplace model we weren't able to
grow because of the chef's we were
supply constrained in the personalized
dinner model we actually weren't able to
grow really fast because of the
customers the even though it was
personalized the food wasn't better than
the best takeout that you could order so
if you want to change the world or
change your industry you have to do
something that is like materially better
like iPhone level better than the market
so people weren't racing to our doors so
we didn't have that ability to grow our
dinner kitten model has the ability to
grow and scale
internally and externally from customer
demand and it also has high retention so
moving on to maybe more about
determination so in the beginning at
Stanford you were a bioengineering major
yes so technical but not a coder
how did you manage actually doing all of
this without being technical yes hmm
well initially um and I mean everyone is
gonna use their skillsets and I think
the one common theme is that in the
first few months you need to you need to
prove your concept you need to have an
MVP you can do that with code you can do
that with sales whatever so I I did not
know how to code um I I learned a PHP
but in both my businesses in the
recruiting business and the chef
business or the food business I have now
I made initial sales without a website
and I proved our concept in the first
three months before any other kind of
funding so with the recruiting business
I did know like Photoshop and design and
I taught myself all of that and loved it
so I enjoyed that and I designed these
like sales packages um that would like
and I made up stuff I was like gold
platinum whatever twenty thousand
dollars and I would like to see if
people would give it to me which is very
bold as a college student um and I like
how to mock up of a website that wasn't
built yet and I took a semester off and
tried and only did sales because that
was my proof of concept and my parents
said that only if I like got a sale
could I not go work on Wall Street which
was horrible
it's a side note I didn't get a sale
that semester and I'm eight I meant like
maybe eighty or so people
I'm through introductions and I went to
go work at Morgan Stanley in 2008 and
that horrible summer and I hated my life
it was like equities trading and three
weeks in I got a check in the mail for
ten thousand dollars cuz it was a
founder founding customer price from
this like law firm and it was like the
coolest day of my life it was revenue it
was validation
and and it took me like you know seven
to ten days to figure out how to quit
the internship people were all like
you'll get blacklisted you'll never get
a job and I told the head of the program
and he said you will always have a job
here but you will never come back and I
thought that I thought that was cleared
at the time and now I fully understand
it and it's because like once an
entrepreneur always an entrepreneur in
your heart in a way so anyways I think I
think the quitting is hard it's a long
story short but it's hard to avoid
so around 2011 2014 you had a hard time
raising money correct so how did you I
mean it's three years how did you fund
all of this and then also at the same
time what did you spend your days doing
it must have been really it's when you
can't get money it's really distracting
like that's a huge distraction so how
did you focus on your business and keep
going
yes so first of all over those three and
a half years of finding product market
fit our monthly burn was $40,000 on
average that's pretty low that's not a
fancy office that's not ten people we
kept it to about four people and
everyone had to be like co-founders
style generalist because we were still
iterating so if you make your burn 40k
you know you can make your 1.5 million
last lasts a while but we raised to
bridge rounds during that time and there
were some some investors who refused to
invest some of them who like saw would
listen to the next iteration and invest
in me both of those bridges were like
200 some K and one critical thing there
was a time in 2013 when no one would
invest in me
and I was running out of all of my money
and we had like one one payroll in the
bank
I think our bank was like $8,000 or
something and that's when I did YC so I
didn't do YC at the beginning of gobble
I did YC three and a half years into the
struggle when I was I didn't know I was
about to figure it out everybody had
lost faith and I'm the only one who had
faith and the only money I could get was
from Jessica
and PG and so I did YC and they said
they would help me raise a series a like
they would fund me for three more months
and six months after that we figured out
our fifteen minute one pan dinner kit so
you Michigan employees during this hard
time how did you keep them motivated to
you know keep going that's a tough one
um I think that there's a lot of
turnover in the early days and even in
like the later days after venture
financing and you're learning how to
hire execs but the employees that ended
up lasting the longest were by referral
and so there was some like shared values
and shared trust there and I also really
clued them into the hard times sometimes
you think you're protecting people by
not telling them but actually your
closest employees especially when you're
four to six if you bring them into the
challenge and if they are challenge
oriented they will stay with you but if
you hide it then they're not really
feeling that excitement and that
challenge at what point you said that
you got an acquisition off or one of
your investors wanted you to just get
acquired by the clothing startup
clothing start absolutely yes I mean
you're having a hard time in here's like
potentially money in your bank account
what was your thought process in just
turning that down yeah um I've I've
thought a lot about this right now even
in our space there's a lot of
consolidation in the food space in the
meal kit space if you like see the news
it's very popular drama in the news um
it's I mean there's all these companies
like Facebook or snapchat or this or
that that I've turned down different
offers over time and sometimes it's
right sometimes it's wrong judged by
society and I just see so much potential
in gobble and once we early on it was
just that early on I turned that
clothing startup thing down in that
product market fit time because this is
what I want to work on and I had I have
nothing to lose I didn't have kids or
whatever and I I just didn't imagine a
better life than working on working on a
heart problem and now
we've started like you know doubling or
tripling year-on-year and so if someone
were to acquire us now and we can't
weather the storm of a bad meal kit
market I think we're like leaving
billions on the table speaking of
competition there's been billions of
dollars in venture funding going into
competitors or so-called competitors
like Reaper and plated and so forth I
mean you're the original company what do
you think about was like all that money
is going over there but you're like I'm
here surviving I'm growing fast you know
what's really going in your mind yeah
well you know we can look at the silver
lining of it which is that necessity
breeds invention and so by not having
that much money we didn't get
comfortable and we had to innovate and
we had to have good numbers so I'm not
saying that we should all starve our
companies but because we were like
somewhat cost starved we didn't I wasn't
distracted by lots of fancy things and I
just focused on making all the dollars
count and doing something meaningful so
you talk about mission but beyond that
what actually really like how did you
keep going over the 78 years like is it
genetic like what what do you think it
really is beyond just the mission Wow
hmm man maybe it is some kind of like
nature nurture thing if it's the mission
is a big part of it but with regards to
the grit and determination thing from in
like early age I think I just my parents
wanted me to go to this school this like
all-girls school and I hated my current
school I was bullied a lot and there was
like like bad phrases and racist things
on my locker and like bad stuff and I
applied to this girl's school in
kindergarten and I didn't get in
and then in first grade and I didn't get
in and in second grade and I didn't get
in and you had to take this er B test
and then like in those early grades
they're asking you like what's a
triangle or something right and I didn't
get in so I was like what's going on and
my parents weren't donating and there's
all these other factors I didn't know
and so I kept applying like third grade
fourth grade fifth grade didn't get in
and I remember one time my parents were
like the test is coming up this is for
your future you need to do this and I
was just so mad I like I just remember
being so defeated and so distraught and
like I was letting them down and I
didn't want to take the test I was like
who needs the school like forget it it's
stupid and I took the test and I still
didn't get in um and finally in seventh
grade I got into that school and it
changed my life I used every resource
they had I started new organizations
I got funding from the principal of the
school to like start a Model UN Society
and like I saw it in a different way and
I just I seized the entire opportunity
when I was there because I knew how
special it was and I worked so hard to
get there and so somehow early on like
that was one experience but there were
experiences like that that I just
learned that life is about hard work and
it's about lead bullets and I'm always
enamored by these real overnight
successes I think the most overnight
successes are like ten years in the
making
there are some flukes that are like one
year two year three years that the media
celebrates in a disproportionate amount
and I'm always very enamored by them but
the only way that I know is like this
lead bullets grit do not give up
strategy you are a very ambitious third
grader thank you I wish that we had
known you back then we would just
predict it all this in front of you all
the way back in kindergarten that would
have been great so you talk about
obviously never quitting but are there
do you think there are reasons to quit I
I guess I like quit kind of on my first
startup and on one of the iterations of
gobble and the only reasons I have ever
quit is because I think the what I was
doing didn't have enough impact in in
the broader world or fulfilment and for
me and meaning and purpose for me I
thought
this question and those are the only
reasons I have quit in the past I think
though that said I think if if the
environment evolves and you can't keep
up with it and things are just waste
surpassing you then then that would be a
really like hard look in the mirror and
I I would may need to quit in that in
that instance so not getting comfortable
and constantly iterating and being not
dogmatic is important a good example of
that is Netflix Netflix evolved to stay
alive there are a lot of big titans of
industry that fell along the way because
they couldn't evolve so two more
questions and then we'll take questions
from the audience one is can you when
you look back are there just like are
the decisions that you made in the early
days that you're thankful that you may
that were really critical to your
success success and if so what were they
well I'll talk about two so one of them
is that one of them is something a lot
changed when we hired our executive chef
Tomas Ricci and and it wasn't just
because we hired a chef to make
consistent food and good food and like
safe food in a kitchen what we gained
though was the ability to innovate in
food and what I have learned is what I
would suggest to an entrepreneur is that
real entrepreneurship comes from diverse
perspectives and from innovating at the
edge of different industries it's really
hard just to get ten homogeneous
engineers in a room and like make
something incredible
you have to have other experts in like
consumer or food or something whatever
else is in your industry to really find
those little insights so once so our
success came from innovating and
technology and personalization but a lot
from innovating in food and doing that
prep work and sending these food
packages in a way that no other company
sends them that's not trivial
so making room for creativity in
different areas of your business is
important and we didn't have that
creativity when the suppliers were just
contractor chefs the second thing was
I have to thank adora she is way too
humble when I had no money and I did YC
and I like swallowed my pride we were
still doing that personalized dinner
service and somehow like I got matched
up with adora and we didn't even fit out
by demo day like we raised 200k on demo
day was nothing it wasn't the right
timing we hadn't figured it out and that
we had just hired our chef like maybe
six weeks or four weeks before a demo
day so I started working with him and
innovating with him and focusing on our
future and and meeting with adora at her
office and anyways I came to her and I
told her about this this meal kit idea
this 15 minute prep kit back in 2014 and
and she was she was like just so like
scary to me and really badass and really
like aggressive and she was like ooh
Sh'ma and she was like if this is it
you need a [ __ ] do it it's just like
you need to do it now and I was like
okay and she was like how fast can you
do it and you kind of want to impress
people something like I don't know like
two weeks she's like great and she was
like and so I mean she basically was
like she's like she was like it was we
had four weeks so she was just like it
was in July and I remember because it
was August first and she's like do it by
August first I was like okay great and
she probably like I don't even know she
remembers all of that but that's what I
thought of every single day for 30 days
and I shut down that personalized dinner
service and we were doing maybe like one
and a half to two million and ARR but it
wasn't going anywhere and the food
wasn't different enough and when we had
tested and are indeed these like prep
kits where people cook it themselves and
feel like a superhero that was magical
in our in our testing and our customer
visits so within 30 days we just rip the
band-aid off shut down that business was
the highest revenue making iteration
that we had ever built with every
iteration we made more revenue
ultimately even though we shut it down
and then on August third we launched
this thing and I emailed adora this like
long email up here the screenshots
here's this and not like I was using her
to hold myself accountable and I was
like it's launched you know and and that
was the best decision of our lives and
so just
need to execute and the other lesson is
like finding people who are in your
corner you need people who are in your
corner and it's okay to not talk to the
ones who aren't but finding people who
are in your corner who you can use as an
inspiration to motivate you is really
critical for speed oh yeah one of the
things I tell people just do it already
you know exactly idea stop just stop
meddling just do it okay so last
question for me is 50 to 100 years from
now
Kabul is gonna be even bigger it is
today but what is what do you think it's
gonna be Wow I you know in the 50 to 100
year vision I actually want gobble to be
let's call it the Disney of the home and
I my thing with gobble is about creating
magical experiences at home that are
easy and fit into this busy life um for
any for any kind of person like single
parents hourly working you know affluent
people I think there's I think that with
all this technology and all this fast
food we've over instrumented a lot of
industries and I was missing that
connection and I think at the end of the
day when our lives are over all we care
about are the moments with our loved
ones and so if I can facilitate some of
that whether it's with learning whether
it's with dinner or food and I'll keep
evolving with the environment I think
that's a worthy cause that's interesting
so it's go me more than just food yeah
we're working on a few other things
around like education and learning and
things like that awesome
cool all right so who has questions like
you see them in progress and they really
made progress but now the life I don't
know what I do
so what do you suggest what kind
suggestion for you half of those people
right or in that situation
and now they're like yeah so I think the
question is around that there are like
environmental constraints and legal
constraints like with regard to
immigration and h-1b and things like
that that prevent people from being
where they want to be with their
customer if you have to Newton full time
but you have to live in another country
is that what you're asking
[Music]
mm well I I know one of my good friends
had a similar problem and these are very
tactical things like they establish some
like shell company and then one of the
investors was a put-on as a board member
and then that board member sponsored the
sponsorship but you're really the CEO of
the company and so there are like I
think first of all getting that like
h-1b visa is insane right and we had
someone we have people who can't get
that visa so gobble actually has an
engineering team in India and in South
Africa and like we're just waiting for
the visas and it's been some people have
been waiting for like 14 months and
they're still working for us remotely so
in those situations that's nuts and now
there's very few loopholes but if you
already are here sometimes there is some
things you can do I think like YC has
helped with some of that stuff if you're
making revenue and you have an actual
company going there's ways to go about
it I would just talk with a lawyer
yeah um interesting so we've done a lot
like oh yeah sorry question is tell us
about the pricing strategy for gobble
and how our pricing strategy evolved
pricing is a big part of product market
fit so you know it has to be priced
appropriately for your market initially
we had different offerings at different
prices on our marketplace in a if you're
at a scrappy company the best tool for
pricing experimentation is email because
it's hard to put like different prices
all over your website for different
users so what I would do is email people
and I have a zillion things in beta all
the time so I'd email our existing
customers and I'd say hey here's a beta
on premium dinners or here's a beta on
value meals or here's a beta on our wine
program and I would I would first do all
the research of the market and then send
people like different clusters of people
three different prices and in the early
days I did it with like 20 people each
and then now I do it like thousands of
people each so um and in the early days
it was a plain text email and I would
say like would you and then sometimes to
each individual person I would send
three plans so I'd say do you want plan
a B or C and so that you can send
different groups different sets of three
plans or you can send different groups
different pricing for one product but I
would you just basically you multiply
the profit times how many people buy it
and whichever one wins and most profit
is your best price
thank you my seeds really grow having a
co-founder the question is that YC is
very Pro having a co-founder and that I
did it on my own for a while can I talk
about that hmm when I started gobble I
looked for a co-founder and I spent I I
kind of just started it like I found
chefs on Craigslist and I was delivering
food in my car but I was dating
co-founders that are now otherwise see
founders at the time and no one at that
time in that like three four month
period was willing to quit their job and
join me or was randomly as passionate
about my idea as I was so it was a
unique this was all very organic I
didn't really think you know I must have
a co-founder or I must be a solo
co-founder I tried to find one and my
priority was like leaping on this idea
and so I didn't find one and I just went
with it um long term I think it is hard
very hard as a single founder right now
our exec team operates kind of like as a
as a hive mind and I share everything
with them so after many many years now
we have like a five person super team
that's all very invested and kind of
like a co-founding team but at scale in
the early day is what I say for single
founders is you kind of have like if
you're swimming in the ocean it's kind
of like a net buoy system so you have to
find like three or six people that are
like those orange buoys and you're
swimming by yourself and you're super
super tired and when you want to rest
you like swim over to one of the buoys
and you hug it and you like talk to them
and they help you but then since you
don't have a co-founder no one can be
your rock right so next time you're like
you know need to rest you swim over to
another buoy and you hug that you know
and you're kind of like you you
basically crowdsource your co-founder
from other founders and friends and you
have to really find and in fact some of
my closest friends were other single
founders and so I had a group of like
two or three single founders and we all
like would constantly meet up for coffee
or drinks after work and trade stories
and help each other yes how's your life
changed
see you now versus when you started what
were the lows what were the highs Wow or
please I apologize so the question is
how has your role as CEO change from
beginning to what it is now
must've been dramatic yes okay um in the
beginning one of the highs is just that
you
you're constantly innovating like that
that 24/7 maker time is very precious to
me
my contrast now my day is like full of
meetings like meetings meetings meetings
meetings and then dinners and so
yesterday I get home at like 11:00 p.m.
today we're starting at 8:00 a.m. and
it's like really full and I have and I
have to fight for strategic time and
maker time and we still need that to
like keep evolving right so I cherish
that part of the early days obviously
the lows are our when like nobody cares
about you you barely have any customer
is like I'm just sleeping at our office
or laying on our couch and I remembered
in some of the lows I just would put
white paper all over and I'd like slay
on the floor and it'd just be like a
blank slate and I'd be like okay what's
next come up with it and so those are
the lows the highs now are it's it's
really gratifying when people start to
know you and you every time I meet a
customer like in the wild it's it makes
my day and when I get too far from the
customer I actually noticed myself
getting unhappy again I think if you
care about the customer and that
experience long-term all the money will
come okay let's take two more questions
one in the back
[Music]
negro so my question is how do you get
that happening without pestering them
you know like hey well how do you do
that a good manner that's a great
question
the question is in the early days you
have your I think the question is this
that you have your team that you're
working with and your customers but
there are other people that aren't on
your team that help you and they're like
mentors advisors friends how do you get
those people to work with you without
feeling like a pest or that you're
pestering them I had a lot of this so
this is a really good question um two
things one I targeted the right advisors
to help me and I would find out where
they were speaking and and I would wait
till everybody was done talking to them
and be the last one to talk to the
speaker because they would remember me
and then I would walk them to their car
because they were in a rush so again
this is about like psychology and like
what does what does a speaker need to do
they talked to a hundred people you know
they need to go if you carry their bags
to their car you're helping them in a
small little way and you're showing kind
of some respect there that's how I found
like Aaron Patzer from mint.com
back in the day who was one of my early
advisors and some other people that was
a hack to finding the right mentors find
out where they are and like wait and
then follow up the other thing is I only
asked people questions that was in their
wheelhouse so I learned a lot about like
what should I ask this person because
when you spend time with someone who's
like a mentor and let's say you ask me
about like enterprise sales I don't know
anything about I do a little bit but I
don't know a lot about enterprise sales
you know and so it's kind of it makes
them feel bad and it's also a waste of
your time and and and what I would do
with people is I would bring I
structured like a white piece of paper
and three kind of thirds I guess and the
top would be my progress like what have
I done since I last saw you
the next third would be what am i
working on now and the last third would
be one of my challenges
and I was very organized about all the
time that I asked from people and so
they always saw progress and then they
would see their advice like come back
and I would save all my notes so early
in the early days I met Reid Hoffman and
there was this cafe called University
cafe and I went to cafes that only had
paper tablecloths and we would write all
over the tablecloth and then I would
like take even had coffee stains on it
and stuff and I would like take it home
and I still have this box of like those
tablecloths that are like big butcher
papers from like five six years ago and
so it's just like I think about all
those little things and about making
time useful taking notes being prepared
and meeting with the right people I
think also and you mentioned this but I
just want to pull it out as being very
thoughtful the questions you ask and
being very specific and instead of
asking broad questions that could take
hours to answer yeah more likely to get
an answer as a result okay last question
make it good go in the back oh my gosh
thank you so much Wow great question the
question is we talked about hacks with
getting customers and what are the hacks
around getting investors cuz I struggled
with getting investors in the in the
early days I think um as you observe all
your friends everybody has lucky kind of
or easier fundraising rounds and
everyone has hard fundraising rounds so
even if someone has it easy right now
and you have it hard it's okay like it
might be hard for them later and the
stories are very up and down um how do
you get investors Wow it's still tough
for example even last year for our
Series B I had a very difficult time
raising money like it all looks
fantastic and there's lots of news and
videos but it like took every ounce of
my being it was the hardest fundraising
and it's because Amazon acquired Whole
Foods and everyone is afraid of Amazon
so they just thought Amazon's gonna do
gobble and also because blue apron went
public and they don't have a lot of
defense ability and there's lots of
companies that are repackaging groceries
so their stock price went down and that
meant that gobble wasn't going to work
so last year was really really hard what
advice do I have I think that oh here's
one good piece of advice a lot of it is
grit and a lot of it is testing and then
watching what resonates with people and
perfecting your pitch and it's weird to
practice in front of friends but you
should really really do it and have
everything like everyone help you with
your deck and your pitch and that's
that's important but the one advice I
have and this may not be true for
everyone but some founders that are like
Shire or not as confident when they get
to their last slide they say even if and
they say like even if you know the world
ends I will still get you your money
back and investors do not care about
getting their money back that is not
sexy to them you shouldn't say that
founders are kind of like hedging
against themselves and saying don't
worry I'll still protect your money but
you need to uplevel that when you go
talk to investors and not say even if
you need to say you need to say that we
have the potential to be the next big X
like we have the potential to be a ten
billion dollar business in three years
and like pump yourself up like stretch
power pose but you have to end on that
really big high note very strong and
that's that's my piece of advice all
right thank you so much huge well thank
you
you
you